voilà on fait comment la vie dès le 24
mai on voit là j'avais jamais vu la
bande annonce avait pas mal la banda ça
donne envie
alors vous avez fait un truc très
bizarre vous êtes né au maroc
votre père était temime au départ un
caprice et dans les affaires au départ
et hemingway et à 16 ans on lui de venir
en france 2 télé au canada pourquoi
pourquoi au lieu de venir en france
comme si c'était normal parce que quand
on est dans le maghreb je suis pas le
réflexe normal c'est devenu en france
non j'ai pas je pense pas c est
peut-être très français est très
franco-français de dire ça je pense mais
pourquoi je sais pas en fait pourquoi
j'étais au québec parce que je rêvais
d'aller aux états unis et puis c'était
l'amérique en français pour moi oui
et donc j'ai été doublé les oui voilà
c'est pour ça c'est alors ça vous avez
vous ce n'est prendre l'accent québécois
je les prie je les u8 quand je vivais là
bas ou gelé j'ai posté drôle mais c'est
intéressant je pense que valérie le fait
aussi j'ai bien de ses shows elle fait
pas mal arrive aussi commencé non il
faut 12 au boty zeppy positive et si
t'es pas c'était pas ça mais je peux
dentrite julie snyder alors en 92 vous
revenez à paris quand même oui j'arrive
à paris pour un devis ras-le-bol des
québécois comme la façon de parler des
eaux usées n'est rien c'est pas ça c'est
pas ça du tout je voulais prendre des
cours de théâtre et je voulais
travailler en français est pas enfreint
cette fait que je suis arrivé à paris et
je suis arrivé j'ai fait les cours de
théâtre ici à paris au cours florent et
je voulais vraiment le faire en france à
paris parce que je pensais que pour
faire du théâtre français france rsa un
béret lfb
voilà il fallait le faire ici donc je
veux arriver à paris et puis j'ai fait
ça vous effet xxl comme fils j'ai pété
un énorme succès et xxl mais pour vous
c'était formidable de travailler avec
michel boujenah une surtout gérard
depardieu
ouais ouais et quand vous avez commencé
à trouver que gérard depardieu vous a
dit on va s'amuser tous les deux oui oui
c'est vrai vous amuser mais il m'a
rassuré beaucoup parce qu'en fait la
première scène du film qu'on devait
tourner avec gérard depardieu
moi j'étais vachement impressionné et
puis la première scène du film mon
premier jour de tournage c'était une
scène dans un bar où la situation la
scène écrite il venait me voir et je
devais lui dire c'est bon on prend pas
la tête c'est pas le moment et avec
gérard depardieu qui venait
ouais en face de moi j'arrivais pas à
balancer j'arrivais pas lui dire vas tu
as encore et donc on a dû refaire plein
de fois la prise jusqu'au moment où il
m'a dit on va s'amuser ça m'a rassuré
vous avez eu d'où ces infos j'ai toutes
les infos alors vous ai fait du théâtre
s'atteler tout contre c'était de
décembre 98 99
ouais vous avez rencontré anne brochet
qui est devenu votre compagne et elle
vous a dit on va s'amuser tous les deux
vous avez toutes les infos ici et vous
amuser avec depardieu beaucoup et à non
ce qu'il dit gad elmaleh dix ans quand
on est un petit peu connus on se demande
si les filles sont amoureuses de vous de
la colonne morris
ouais j'appelle ça une colonne morris
non mais j'ai pas où j'ai dû dire ça
mais voilà je me suis dit je suis guide
en bon vous rêvez toujours de l'amérique
oui toujours et oui ça me fascine mais
c'est vrai beaucoup de fascination pour
la mairie qui parle en anglais cette
fois à huy qui parle en anglais le
cinéma américain j'ai beaucoup de
fascination